حررت خرسانه واحتفل سكانها او ما تبقى
منهم بقوتهم المسلحه انتهت نشوه النصر
لتكشف عن حمل ثقيل من المشكلات القصف
الروسي والمتكرر على البنيه التحتيه خصوصا
محطه توليد الكهرباء والطاقه عدا عن
الدمار الواسع في المباني ترك المدينه
تعاني بشده حل الشتاء ثقيلا ونحن لازلنا
في بدايهته ليبدو ان الرهان الروسي على
الفصل القاسي بدا ياتي ثماره فموسكو تعمدت
تدمير هنا التحتيه للطاقه لتركيع الجاره
الغربيه خيرسون وميكولايف المدينه
الجنوبيتان الاكثر تضررا اليوم لا كهرباء
لماء عذب ولا معناه كافيه تسد الذره مكه
وترحم السكان من قسوه الشتاء
والحلو ماساوي هكذا تفكر الحكومه
الاوكرانيه بجديه باجلاء سكان خرسون
وميكولايف نحو مناطق يستطيعون فيها البقاء
على قيد الحياه مع برد شتاء قد يصل الى 30
درجه تحت الصفر نائب رئيس الوزراء
الاوكرانيه
قالت انه في الايام القليله المقبله ستبدا
الحكومه في مساعده الاشخاص الذين يرغبون
في المغادره بالفعل لكنها شددت على ان
السكان سيتخذون قراراتهم الخاصه بشان
البقاء اضافه انه في الوقت الحالي لا حديث
عن اجلان قصري لكن وبما ان مدينه تيمكو
لايف وخيزون هدف متكرر للضربات الصاروخيه
الروسيه فقد طلب سكان المدينه بالانتقال
الى مناطقها اكثر امنا
[موسيقى]
ولتسديد ماساه المدينه والمناطق المحيطه
بهما سقطت ما لا يقل عن اثنتي عشره قذيفه
في محطه للطاقه واتلفت عده اجهزه في اكبر
محطه نوويه في اوروبا تبادلت موسكو
الاتهامات بشان الضربات وكما ذكرنا بالامس
هنا اعتبر المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه
للطاقه الذريه رافاييل جروسي ان اي ان كان
من يقف وراء ذلك يجب ان يتوقف على الفور
وانما يحدث هو لاعب بالنار وفي حصيله
النادره افاد المدعي العام الاوكراني
اندري كوستين بان نحو
437 طفلا يعتقد انهم من بين اكثر من
ثمانيه الاف و300 مدنيه قتلوا منذ بدء
الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا كوستين اضافه
انه في ظل نظره المعلومات الموثوق بها من
المناطق التي تحتلها روسيا فمن المرجح ان
يكون العدد الحقيقي للقتلى اعلى بكثير
فضلا عن اكثر من احد عشر مصابا
ان المدنيين سجلوا في الساعات او ككل في
المجمل نتحدث عن 11,000 مصاب